a prayer for peace in one of the regions
that needs it the most
the Latin patriarch of Jerusalem
presided over the Christmas midnight
mass in bethlehem's Nativity Church
[Music]
Christmas Eve
ly event Bethlehem looks forward to all
year long as celebrations attract
Christians from all over the world to
the traditional birthplace of Jesus but
this season was three years in the
making
festivities were limited for the past
two years due to covid-19 lockdowns
there is a good turnout and tourism is
picking up the table behind me has
customers from turkey and others came
from Ukraine so there are people coming
the Palestinian tourism Ministry says
that the sector is recovering with more
than 500 000 tourists visiting Bethlehem
in 2022. a really nice atmosphere and we
feel at home and it's the spirit of
Christmas compared to more than 3.5
million tourists who visited Palestine
in 2019 this year the number of foreign
tourists is just shy of 1 million this
is not the Boost small shop owners were
hoping for for me if you want to talk
about last year was much better than
this year last year I had a lot of work
on the Arab who lives in the north of
Palestine like the people who lives in
Nazareth and Tiberia area and these
people they came to buy they came in big
numbers because the borders were closed
us up
out of the 900 Palestinian Christians in
Gaza Israeli authorities only granted
600 of them permits to leave to
Bethlehem
one person will be granted a permit but
two others of the same family won't they
always leave someone out so what happens
is that the family ends up not traveling
with more than 220 Palestinians killed
by Israeli forces this year Palestinians
are reminded that they remain under
Israel's occupation the people here say
they try to seize any opportunity to
celebrate they live under Israel's
military occupation and tell us they
don't have much to do but to pray for
peace
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank